you know the natural consequence of
occupy was
at least in part donald trump bernie
sanders
you had right-wing populists left-wing
populists sort of moderate economic
populists
nationalist populists people who just
said for the people by the people not
the elite the establishment revolving
door bs
and so you go from 2011 eventually
occupy got dominated by
leftists but a lot of the regular there
was a lot of regular traditional liberal
types moderate lefty types
they flipped for trump so when you had
this
uprising sort of this this emergence of
these populists
and then it came to political candidates
populist bernie sanders emerges populist
donald trump emerges well guess what
donald trump is he i don't know there's
a lot of words people use to describe
him
but uh i think tough is probably a good
one
you can call him you can call him stupid
small hand orange face or whatever
but the dude is stronger than than these
people on the left
bernie sanders couldn't hang and so he
gets knocked out donald trump ends up
winning
yes he has that tough personality that
people naturally are
kind of attracted to but he also plays
up his anti-establishment more than
anyone else even though sometimes he has
people like john bolton right next to
him what a stupid
which was not a smart move to do but but
he's able to play up on
uh you know his charisma his personality
and when you truly go to one of his kind
of
talks whenever he's doing one of his
rallies it's really an event that's kind
of awestunning
and you really kind of do understand a
lot of people don't understand donald
trump unless they actually go to one of
his rallies one of his meetings
and you really get to see how he's up
there in the moment
and he's a comedian to everyone he's
funny he's funny he's legitimately funny
i think it was dave chappelle that was
talking about
how donald trump came up with the term
kung flu
and he was like i'm not going to curse
here but dave chappelle kirsty who's
like
you know i'm not i'm mad at him he said
that not because it's racially
insensitive
but that's something i should say not
donald trump right
and uh yeah you got you kind of kind of
give it up to him in that way
where he does represent this kind of
anti-establishment
idea but it's an idea but yeah he's not
as smart as sanders they weren't
they weren't afraid of him like they
were of sanders like donald trump put
they were
donald trump put that what's his name
bolton in now he's threatening to repeal
section 230 completely
that's crazy lead insanity like he
doesn't know what he's doing no but you
know what i kind of
i'm kind of digging it you know why well
if the result is either
uh if like if 230 got repealed but he
didn't reauthorize the ndaa i would just
be laughing the whole time
now i'm concerned about our military
personnel for sure but
the things they stuff in that bill the
amount of money they waste the no bid
contracts
trump's like i'm not going to sign the
nda unless you repeal 230
i'm like he's just gonna blow it he's
like blowing the whole thing up like he
won't see
it's him literally pointing the middle
finger to the political establishment
and the military-industrial complex
and it's hilarious i don't know much
about the ndaa i don't i really don't
but i
like it at a service level i would love
to not refund it it seems like a
so straight act it funds the military
it it authorizes the the expenses
towards military and and we spend a
ridiculous amount of money
i was reading there was a tweet matt
tayyip tweeted something out saying that
when you actually break down the costs
even half of republicans agree this is
ridiculous we're spending too much money
and i think the easiest way to put it is
we're building roads in afghanistan and
iraq
or we've been for 20 years and it's kind
of winding down you know with trump
why are we doing that here it's we're
building infrastructure
in other countries it's just it's 20
years of my life we've been doing this
we need to get
tanks from west to east over there yeah
i had to drive down from
upstate new york holy cow that looked
some places looked like
iraq down there i mean yeah and i'm
driving a trailer so this thing's
jumping up and down all the time but
the military industrial complex does
feed off the american people more than
any kind of communist socialist
leech out there you want to talk about
corporate welfare
holy cow when you look at no military
contracts yeah no big contract how can
like where's the free market where's the
where's the capitalism when you have
lockheed martin and boeing
literally sci-fi whoa whoa whoa whoa
those companies are run by women luke
you're not a sexist and uh the new lgbtq
friendly mainstream media approved uh
groups they're gonna put rainbow like
they're gonna put rainbow flags on
hellfire missiles i mean
i'm i'm not even there's a photo of this
like people were pointing it out like
this is what their plan is it's a it's a
reaper drone and they put the symbols on
it like that makes it okay
yeah it's absolutely ridiculous or joe
biden's gonna have fancy socks that's
what we're gonna have
with the mainstream media coming up in
the next four years fancy joe biden
socks
and look how great this person is drone
bombing a wedding in yemen
uh but they won't even talk about that
or how you know the united states is
with al qaeda in yemen and that's a
whole other
donald trump discussion could run into a
burning building to save a box of
puppies
and they would criticize him for being
reckless and endangering
well he as much as we're critical of him
he is the president this is
extremely reckless no matter what he
does it's bad
donald trump literally killed american
citizens people don't know this
i rant as much as i can i remember you
asked it was you you asked was it
charlie gibbs
yeah obama's spokesperson and one of his
top cabinet members
me and sierra adamson during the
presidential debates when
barack obama was running against mitt
romney went up to him and he and we
asked him
a question that no one asked ever why
did you kill an american
why did you and this is important to
understand here barack obama physically
signed off on every drone strike
physically made the approval for sending
out
killer robots to drone bomb innocent
people 90
of which were found out according to the
intercept with the government documents
that they were able to find
90 of which were innocent civilians
so you know when you have such an
egregious case especially with the case
of a 16 year old
american citizen from colorado that was
assassinated under this
deposition matrix it's not this position
yeah disposition matrix
you know they make up all these fancy
words for it it's assassinated
yeah it's a kill list it's a killer
that's essentially it is barack obama
granted himself the ultimate power of
fewer able to assassinate and kill any
american citizen anywhere in the world
now at any time
under his own decree no court no judge
no lawyer no legal arguments
and he did it and he carried it out now
here's what here's where it comes into
the ndaa
so donald trump tweets out unless they
repeal section 230 i'm going to veto the
national defense authorization act
that's crazy it's really crazy i mean
repealing section 230 would destroy the
internet no joke like it would be the
end of independent media right cnn would
be laughing all the way to the bank
because they got lawyers they can afford
it
now smaller channels definitely can
independent media definitely can't if
230 goes
this channel won't exist youtube will
start banning everybody left and right
youtube will become netflix overnight
where they sign off on every bit of
content
and they want it so a lot of people said
this is trump's big ask right
he says repeal 230 that way they walk it
down to reform no
no no no no the democrats the
establishment the
the rhinos the never trumpers they're
begging to get rid of 230
because the only challenge they've ever
had is when the people were able to
communicate with each other and they've
been desperately trying to ban people
give them an excuse so now going back to
obama obama signed off on something
called the indefinite detention
provision
it was added to the national defense
authorization act i think in what 2012
yes it allows the government to
indefinitely detain anybody
anywhere for effectively any reason even
american citizens
obama signed that so now you have in
this country
what 80 million people they say who
voted for biden assuming that's you know
the correct and final number many of
whom don't know anything about the
democratic party
don't know what uh obama was don't know
what biden was
and now they're cheering like we did it
we defeated fascism it was like yes the
fascists who was pulling our troops out
of these countries who was
drawing down our you know started no new
wars great now we're going back to the
obama era
yeah it just boggles my mind to to see
so many people call donald trump a
fascist he's a fascist meanwhile where
were you during the obama administration
where he legally codified
assassinating spying torturing killing
executing any american citizen at any
time that he wants to
and these are the powers that he gave
donald trump and now
there's other people telling donald
trump hey use some of these powers
let's invoke martial law and uh it's
just it's just
i think i think directly yeah i think
we're being played
uh like a fiddle here i think it's
important to pay attention more than
ever
and these issues especially the obama
administration we need to revise
what happened under obama because this
is obama 2.0
slash more corporatist of a presidency
coming in with joe biden
joe biden who argued that there should
be more corporate lobbying inside of the
white house
not less so that's the major
disagreement that obama had with bayern
biden wanted
more so special interests but something
interesting is going to happen
in their desperation the establishment
tried to activate as many people as
possible to vote
so i'm talking to my friends now and
they're like you know i know this guy he
posted a picture of himself voting you
know
he's dropping the mailbox or mail in
ballot and i was and he was like you
gotta vote for biden everybody and so i
you know challenged him a bit like why
and he's like you know trump is is
undermining our democracy and said all
these things
and then i just went through a list of
obama-era you know policies where biden
was
the vp and he's like well i don't know
about supporting all that i mean i
wasn't really paying attention back then
and i was like so will you acknowledge
you voted in a guy who oversaw
his brother and family getting rich
flying his son on air force two to get
this equity deal
and blowing up kids and now but here's
the point i'm going to make
when you say where were you when obama
was doing all this oh they were asleep
and you know what i'm not going to drag
him for that but guess what
if you think i'm going to sit back and
and joe biden gets to come in
and start blowing up kids again blowing
up you know innocent civilians 90
percent
drone striking and trump was doing drone
strikes too i criticized him for that
i'm gonna i'm gonna hold these people
figuratively to the flame
i'm gonna be like wow you supported this
this is great so tell me now how do you
feel about these kids
yeah trump not only uh you know
supported and continued these policies
he also got rid of the provision
that made the reporting of him not
existent so we still don't know
exactly what donald trump did because he
got rid of that but one of the videos
that i'm most proud of that i did before
was during a presidential election where
i went up to random people and i read
off obama's policies but i told them
that they were mitt romney's policies
and i'm like mitt romney
wants to assassinate american citizens
mitt romney wants to spy on you mitt
romney
wants to torture american citizens and
mitt romney
and all the people all the people that
are interviewed i was like this is
romney and then they're like this is
horrible we got to stop it we got to
fight them
and of course these are all barack obama
supporters and then at the end of the
video i'm like well actually i got to be
honest with you i lied to you
these weren't these weren't the policies
of mitt romney these are the policies
that the guys you're voting for and
supporting
and you know but there's a little bit
this is tribalism man yes it's all party
politics tribalism the divide and
conquer
agenda that's being said out that makes
people hate each other over these little
imaginary gang rules that are just
absolutely ridiculous and insane
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you